know sometimes you just see a movie
that's just been memed up so much that
you don't know if it's actually good
just pick what we want it's a good movie
i'll stand by that i just can't stand
the minions i should love steve carell
he's just so charming yeah but there's
other movies with him in it that don't
involve minions i don't mind the minions
that much really i i i hate it when they
made the minions more of a thing because
yeah later on because they're so popular
so it's not that much of a thing in the
first movie not as much okay i just hate
the fact that minions just never died in
japan like it's it's
why why why has it not died in japan i
did i did walk past a clothing store the
other day that was all minions called oh
no i walked i walked past a minion saw
in akihabara as well a minion store yeah
in akihabara imagine weebs
disappointment when they go to akihabara
and the first thing they see is a
[ __ ] minion store i mean it is anime
in japan
that is true
why do they not have that with other
pixar dreamworks films why do we not
have a shrek where's the shrek store
i want a shrek style shrek's too ugly to
be popular in japan no yeah where's the
cars store
i believe that's called a dealership it
wasn't car cars was like pixar's most
successful franchise monetarily because
of all the merchandise is it is it
actually yeah because they sold so many
toys and figures i believe you can look
that up actually but i'm near certainly
but it's not minions no no because think
about think about it right cars as a
franchise right think of all the merch
you can make from cars
kids love cars all i can think of is
like hot wheels yeah that's right you
can literally make like a bazillion
different types of like car merchandise
it's so easy but japan has proved that
you can make a bazillion different types
of minions merch as well
i see more minions merged than i does
does cars have an entire [ __ ] store
in harbor i don't think so
it doesn't matter i'm telling you man
he's looking at he's googling it as we
speak he's taking so long though this is
the worst fact-checking epc like you
could probably make a video of i spent
an entire year on nothing but minions
merch yeah you could yeah i'm pretty
sure there's enough food
probably bananas
they have the minion minion popsicle
have you seen that yeah you see those
youtube videos are people trying um
this youtube series where people just
try and get the popsicles to look like
the characters yeah yeah yeah but they
never look like it they never look like
them and they're trying to get them as
close as possible that shit's so random
yeah i did say like i did see the clip
on twitter oh like this guy the
spongebob one that actually looks like
it and the guy like freaks out he's like
i finally fell
because they never look like spongebob
like it's just completely like is this
like official popsicles or popsicles
that people make like yeah like official
like collabs
open they pull it out and it never looks
like the characters right so people are
like obsessed with trying to find ones
that look like the characters i used to
eat the toy story ones religiously
they had toy stores yeah they had like a
woody one in australia it like
and it looked hideous
is it is it just because i've moved to
japan that i've noticed this or do japan
japanese merchandise have like so many
collaborations like more than you have
women oh yeah like more than you would
expect than in other
countries of course they have like 20
times any promotional thing ever because
japan is so good at milking out
something that's popular until it's like
dry as a bone yeah because it's like it
was so weird every time i go to like the
supermarket or the company and i swear
every there's there's a different
collaboration going on every time
there's it's like if there is not a
collaboration going on i'm sure it's
like japan's going through a typhoon or
something or like a natural disaster
just happened right like it's always
like the coffees
or the ice creams or something it was
demon slayer coffees for a bit now it's
jujitsu and coffee i don't like that
because to me it's like if you just
sticking the character on the [ __ ]
that's that's just the tacky that's
[ __ ] lazy man what do you make it
taste like his piss or something
okay
do people die for that [ __ ] though it's
the thing it's like collecting
collectors are all over that [ __ ] dude
like it's that's the thing that the
inside has nothing to do with the
character or the franchise yeah it's
just on the [ __ ] package
i don't know it's like i don't know it
makes less rubbish maybe [ __ ] i don't
know it's like there was so i went to
the company right right they had a
demon slayer fried chicken right i
assume demon slayer fried chicken what
do you think it is what do you think it
is what makes a demon slayer fried
chicken i don't know how you do
absolutely nothing it's just got it the
box it comes in has [ __ ] tanjiro and
nezuko on it and and and the flavor is
what's the most demon slayer flavor you
can think of
demon right not a [ __ ] cod row
just cod rope and cheese or something i
was like what is this
[ __ ] demon slayer
what was bts about the bts mcdonald's
meal i i did i never got it so actually
uh or the travis scott meal as well yeah
well that yeah that was marketing right
yeah it was just yeah yeah i guess the
they had bts on the bag
well it did this job because i heard
about it i had never never even bought
that [ __ ] meal but uh you know did
you see that like they have bts collabs
here with like uh like anything there
was one that was uh mint it was a btsm
mint collaboration
which is like mints
and i was like okay
like cool so
like what's going to do with bds i i
think it's i think it's pretty cool in
the sense though because there is cool
yeah i mean i mean japan do so many
collabo like so many collaborations that
some of them are just really [ __ ]
cool yeah but then you also get a lot of
like you get a lot of misses as well
yeah but like
the coolest one i think i saw was uh it
was eye drops but it had the hatsune
miku at the front of it
but it kind of makes sense because it's
like it was marketed as like you know
it's to help you for people who are like
staring at a screen for a while and also
the liquid was like a hatsune miku
bluish green
so i'm like that collaboration makes
sense yeah right but you know demon
slayer tampons don't make any [ __ ]
sense yeah it's strange are you kidding
me i'll [ __ ] buy demonstrate tampons
how the [ __ ] yeah it's just like
nezuko's mouthpiece
thought you were just going to say demon
slayer coffee doesn't make sense i'm
just like
coffee is coffee the coffee
collaboration is just the one
collaboration where it's it's the clear
file of collaborations right it's when
it's when the people don't know how to
collab and just have run out of ideas
and just like the only time where the
coffee collaboration made sense was when
they did that collab with tokugawa no
that was the
time where i was like finally
it makes sense what does juice what does
jesus chryson have to do with coffee
drink coffee in one episode oh yeah
clearly did you see the
there was like an ice cream demon slayer
one and it was nezuko's like uh biting
thing yeah or like it was something
where it was like a bamboo thing yeah
yeah and it just looked like a dick
[Music]
it was like a stick and you eat it
i don't know what it was but it looked
like a dick it looked like a green dick
this past product design did it
look like a demon slayer like cucumber